seeing so many six kills together this
deep is just incredibly rare
initially they seemed wary of this up
and it's bright lights but not for long
they soon become much more inquisitive
there's another one right in front of me
I literally could reach out and touch it
look look look look oh he's hitting the
SOB oh my gosh oh my gosh that is the
most amazing thing I've ever seen
look at that look at that
we're so close I didn't think we'd be
this close I mean the entire sub is
moving I mean they are they're
shouldering up against us
the whole sub just rocks back and forth
look at this you just Ram this up oh if
they didn't get your heart beat fast I
don't know what will I don't know maybe
they're picking up the electrical
signals that we're giving off in the
submarine there's a lot of hardware on
board and sharks have the ability to
pick up electrical signals sensors in
the Sharks heads detect even the tiniest
Ignis in their preys nerves but that
animals mouthing this up making me very
nervous
soon the six kills are no longer
satisfied just bashing against the sub
what was that I can't be good
you know what I think it was his teeth
on the front of the sub he came up and
fit the part of the sub
three giant sharks that I see but I mean
there was a very distinct loud noise
which scares me
I was nervous enough about just coming
down here in a homemade sub I didn't
realize we'd have a five metre shark
biting it - he bit the front of the sub
more that that's not a confidence
builder
Wow